la conférence de montréal s'est amorcé
aujourd'hui sous le thème vers une
économie plus verte et plus juste y'a
plus de 120 pays dont le canada qui se
sont engagés à atteindre l'objectif de
carboneutralité d'ici 2050 et pour y
arriver les gouvernements les
entreprises les universités les
organisations de la société civile
devront bien sûr unir leurs efforts avec
nous ce soir chantal d'une carpentier
chef du bureau du secrétaire général de
la conférence de l'onu sur le commerce
et le développement
pourquoi madame carpentier en somme elle
s'est fait un plaisir de vous accueillir
d'abord expliquez-nous ce que ce que
vous faites exactement
aux nations unies parce que vous êtes à
new york généralement oui c'est ça donc
je suis la cheffe du bureau du commerce
du de la conférence des nations unies
sur le commerce et le développement dont
nous supportons les pays en
développement dans leur développement
est présentement le développement c'est
le développement durable qui inclut une
transition vers les changements
climatiques et donc on a des mais
surtout la macroéconomie donc j'écoute
toujours votre émission donc tout ce qui
est la dette souveraine
les investissements dans le
développement durable oui donc voilà et
donc vous devez établir des objectifs en
matière de développement durable
là on vient de vivre 18 mois de pandémie
de façon quand même assez intense pour
tout le monde est ce que est ce qu'on a
oublié le développement durable et même
plus que ça l'urgence climatique en fait
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a tous
les investissements qu'on avait fait
depuis 2015 dans les eaux d'aider les
objectifs de développement durable des
nations unies ont été annihilés avec la
pandémie surtout dans les pays en
développement et face et d'oublier
effacer complètement oui oui et donc on
part de loin et ce qui se passe c'est
que on pense que oui avec tout ce qu'on
entend que beaucoup la relance les très
verte est en fait moins de 18 % des
programmes de relance des pays les 50
pays les plus importants en termes de
relance économique on peut être qualifié
de verre et supporter la transition vers
le vert et vers l'est une transition
carboneutre donc les pays investissent
des milliers de milliards de dollars
particulièrement les états unis dans la
relance est ce que est ce qu il ya de la
relève verte dans c'est ce qui en a
assez il y en a pas assez ça c'est clair
parce que on est tous convalescents tir
présentement dans l'économie grise
risque de nous nous nous enfermer dans
cette économie alors qu'on sait très
bien qu'on doit transitionner on sait
tous engagés à avoir du carbone autres
d'ici 2030 et 2050
et pour ce faire il faut des gens à
utiliser les milliers de milliards qu'on
met de l'avant présentement pour entamer
cette transition et non pas de nous nous
enfermer dans ses traits au vieil
économique donc ça vient de l'état ça
vient des choix de l'état ça vient du
secteur privé ça vient du secteur
financier ça vient de tous ces gens
c'est à dire de tous ces gens mais pour
que ça vienne de l'état ce sont notre
panel aujourd'hui ce qu'on discute et on
avait ecotec du québec on donne des
ondes ou est-ce qu'on développe des
nouvelles technologies mais ça prend un
marché pour ces technologies on doit
compétitionner avec les autres
producteurs et donc il faut que nos
gouvernements et des politiques
d'acquisition qui font en sorte que
c'est pô juste le plus beau prix mais
que aussi on donne des points pour les
skis verte qui est une technologie verte
qu'on va acheter pour l'état il faut
investir dans la recherche et le
développement il faut qu'on investisse
dans les partenariats et ce sont des
choses que souvent on oublie ça c'est
des désinvestissements du développement
c'est ce sont des avancées importantes
pour tenter justement de réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
bâton dans le bâton et la carotte c'est
bien sûr la taxe carbone marché du
carbone il ya notamment le marché québec
californie est-ce que de ce côté là
c'est assez ambitieuse quel prix du
carbone est assez haut selon votre
évaluation selon pas mon évaluation mais
les évaluations des experts mondiaux il
ya seulement 5 % des pays qui ont un
prix du carbone qui est assez élevé pour
en fait avoir un
incitatif les prix du carbone devrait
être à 4 40 à 80 dollars pour du site
2030 et de 50 à 100 dollars après
2050 et il sait que seulement 5% des
pays qui sont à ces cris et de toute
façon le prix carbone n'est pas assez
c'est nécessaire mais pas suffisant
parce que on a des fuites de carbone et
donc la commune octo pérenne européenne
comme vous savez on parlait de avoir un
ajustement à la frontière pour le prix
du carbone pour ne pas désavantager les
producteurs européens par contre ce
qu'on voit c'est que ça prend beaucoup
plus que ça et une cata qs carbone à la
frontière n'est pas nécessairement ce
qui est plus efficace parce que ça le
beaucoup d'impact négatif sur les pays
en développement est très peu d'impact
positif pour les producteurs de la
communauté européenne et donc on en
revient toujours à cette question
économique de base est ce que de viser
la réduction des émissions mais même je
vais aller plus loin la carboneutralité
parce que c'est quand même ça l'objectif
éventuellement est ce que c'est un coût
économique ou un bénéfice économique je
pense que si on est un entrepreneur on
voit ça comme une opportunité d'affaires
s'est il faut entamer la transition et
dans cette transition il ya des milliers
de milliards de dollars d'opportunités
pour les entrepreneurs qui trouve des
solutions innovantes le problème c'est
qu'il faut que nos gouvernements donnent
la pluie et montre avec l'exemple
eux-mêmes pour pouvoir avantages et nos
producteurs nationaux et dc du québec sq
ont parlé aujourd'hui aussi pour leur
donner cette fête c'est hélas mais il ya
des hésitations encore de la parole de
la part du secteur privé a posé les
gestes écologiques naisseur je pense que
la pression vient de plus en plus du
secteur financier on a ici la caisse de
dépôt et placement du québec on a
d'autres investisseurs à travers la
planète qui de plus en plus ne mesure
plus seulement le risque et le retour
sur les investissements mais le risque
de retour et les impacts et de plus en
plus on parle d'une standardisation des
de la mesure des impacts sociaux et
environnementaux des entreprises et ça
avance très très rapidement et de plus
en plus les fonds de pension les fonds
souverains les grosses familles
demandent à ce qu'on ait un impact et
qu'on le mesure est donc ça fais une
pression sur nos entreprises très
intéressant chantal line carpentier
merci d'avoir été avec thor ça me fait
grand plaisir merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit